bonsoir gamme lamelles larrère le plan
de l'europe donc un pour mettre au pas
les gaffes à une réaction on arrive à un
tournant
enfin est-ce que c'est trop tard trop
tôt le bon timing
moi je pense que c'est un petit peu
opportuniste comme législation
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on ait
dépassé sur le plan économique par les
gaffes a qui sont devenus absolument
colossaux en termes de chiffre
d'affaires mais aussi en termes de
services et je suis pas sur moi à titre
personnel qu'on arrive à avoir des
champions européens en renforçant
quelque part la législation je sais pas
si c'est le meilleur levier pour les
concurrencer
en tout cas c'est une technique déjà été
employée avec le rg et finalement ça
n'a pas eu les effets espérés
et ça va même décourager un certain
nombre d'acteurs européens de m donc je
sais pas si il faut toujours faire
attention quand on veut créer des
législations spécifiques pour des
secteurs particuliers alors l'idée est
de sanctionner avant de constater les
dérives c'est le bien de cela qu'il
s'agit est ce qu'on prend le problème
dans le bon sens alors la législation
n'est pas encore prête un les
dispositions dont on parle au niveau
européen ils seront sans doute voté
d'ici un an et où on est dans des effets
d'annoncés déjà pour jouer aussi le bras
de fer avec peut-être l'administration
maiden qui va se mettre en place et donc
pouvoir négocier des accords sur le
numérique mais pas que puisque les états
unis regardent aussi lors gaza
aujourd'hui avec circonspection
mais il ya aussi d'autres enjeux
d'autres accords qui pourraient venir
dans la balance et les états unis ont
intérêt à avoir des champions numérique
fort et donc peuvent faire des
concessions aussi sur d'autres points
donc il ya aussi un agenda européen qui
qui pourrait être concomitant à 7 à ces
annonces alors on a vu que les sanctions
étaient sales et jusqu'à 10% du chiffre
d'affaires mondial
est ce qu'on peut imaginer aujourd'hui
que ces sanctions puissent être un jour
mises en oeuvre dans la dans la vraie
vie
alors aujourd'hui il ya des sanctions de
plus en plus forte qui sont déjà prises
1er gp des vagues jusqu'à sur le
règlement sur la protection des données
personnelles va jusqu'à 10% des du
chiffre d'affaires mondial des
entreprises
aujourd'hui on la semaine dernière la
cnil a annoncé des sanctions énormes
jusqu'à 80 millions d'euros contre
google et 40 millions contre amazon
donc on est déjà dans des montants qui
sont très loin d'être dérisoire il ya
apple qui s'est fait également
sanctionné récemment par l'irlande pour
enfin sur des questions fiscales et donc
on voit bien aujourd'hui que la
régulation du numérique
elles arrivent les sanctions elles sont
déjà là après est-ce que ça va permettre
vraiment parce que le sujet cacher c'est
le retard pris par l'europe sur le sujet
du numérique sur le développement de
grandes plateformes et ça je sais pas si
les résultats va être atteint en tout
cas google a réagi ce soir non sommes
nous inquiète a dit l'entreprise que les
propositions formulées par la commission
européenne semble cibler spécifiquement
une poignée d'entreprises en est rompue
difficile le développement de nouveaux
produits afin de soutenir les pme en
europe en sont déjà un petit chantage
google at elle raison telle raison
d'être inquiet alors je sais pas je sais
pas si google a des raisons immédiates
d'être inquiet c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui
les gaffes à google mais aussi facebook
et consorts sont attaqués de toutes
parts ils sont un petit peu le coupable
idéal pour les politiques qui n'y voient
voilà le responsable de tous les maux de
la société notamment sur les sujets de
liberté d'expression finalement ça
serait toujours la responsabilité de
cette plate forme mais finalement que
fait la justice puisqu'il ya il ya déjà
des règles qui existent
peut-être que si on faisait appliquer
plus souvent les règles déjà existantes
on n'aurait pas besoin des deux 2 de
recourir ensuite aux gaffes à et leur
demander de devenir les gendarmes à la
place des gendarmes alors on sort
effectivement je les ai à une forme de
chantage en tout cas de voilà on vous
prévient le développement de nouveaux
produits afin de soutenir les pme en
europe parce qu'il est un vrai danger a
gêné les pme en europe
avec cette initiative ce qui est certain
c'est qu'aujourd'hui pour faire du
commerce en ligne
on doit placer par ces grandes
plateformes on doit passer on doit
référencer son site sur google est donc
aujourd'hui google consent des gros
efforts pour accompagner notamment les
pme sur les usages digitaux pour allait
s'adresser également auprès de tous les
deux tous les internautes de tous les
consommateurs
on l'a vu ces derniers mois on pouvait
même plus se rendre dans un certain
nombre de commerces et donc la planche
de salut pour beaucoup d'entreprises
physique finalement c'est de ceux
numérisés s'est passé au numérique et
donc les grandes plates formes en
conflit ont aussi accompagné cette
transformation cette transition
numérique et c'était peut-être aussi là
le rôle des états que d'accompagner les
les pme aujourd'hui c'est google et
d'autres plateformes qui assure ce rôle
et c'est un rôle de service public pour
moi donc il ya un an
il ya un petit problème des genres mais
c'est pas que de la faute des dégâts
fars merci ian hamel larrère docteur en
droit spécialiste du numérique